[Musique]
bonsoir jacques d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau alors à quelle sauce on va être
mangés en 2022 ce que cette réforme tant
annoncée
elle va arriver déjà et qu'elle forme
surtout va-t-elle prendre vous avez tout
à fait raison on est aujourd'hui
absolument dans le flou la seule chose
que l'on sait c'est que en 2017 lors de
la précédente campagne macron s'était
engagé à faire une réforme structurelle
la fameuse réforme par points puis dans
le cours du mandat il avait commencé à
évoluer sous la pression des bois
philippe vers l'idée que ça comprendrait
aussi des éléments de réforme
paramétrique et là ce qui nous a annoncé
dans son allocution du 9 novembre et
bien en réalité c'est une réforme
purement paramétrique avec un
allongement de l'âge de départ à 64 ou
65 ans donc en cinq ans mais il a fait
les quelques centimètres qui le séparait
de françois fillon tout ça pour ça et
alors quels sont les arguments en faveur
d'un simple allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite alors il
fondamentalement il ya deux arguments le
premier c'est évident et évidemment
l'allongement de la durée de vie et ça
on le voit bien
2950 à 2019
l'espérance de vie a augmenté de 16 ans
pour les hommes et pour les femmes
l'arrière toujours un fort décalage il
ya grosso modo 4 années de décalage
entre les femmes et les hommes mais
grosso modo on a pris 16 ans depuis 1950
mais c'est pas du tout le cas sur le lhc
dur l'espérance de vie en bonne santé et
ça c'est quand même extrêmement
important parce que ça veut dire est ce
que les gens profiteront d'une certaine
manière de leur retraite et là ce que
l'on voit c'est que bon pour les hommes
ça progresse mais très légèrement pour
les femmes c'est grosso modo instable et
c'est stable à 64 ans alors en plus ce
que l'on sait aussi c'est qu'il ya
d'énormes différences suivant les
catégories sociales
on sait que les employés les ouvriers
pour eux la vie l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé elle se situe plutôt autour
de 60 ans il ya même certaines
professions ou c'est 58 59 ans par
contre pour les csp + et csp dit plus
plus on est plutôt autour de 68 70 ans
donc là il ya un vrai problème et on
voit très bien que tout allongement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite eh bien ça
va pénaliser prioritairement les
personnes des classes populaires et le
deuxième argument alors deuxième
argument bas c'est tout simplement un
argument de coincer c'est ce que coûtent
aujourd'hui le système de retraite et
c'est très net il voulait aujourd'hui la
france dépense à peu près 14 % 13 8% du
pib dans ces retraites alors c'est
nettement plus que l'allemagne
l'allemagne et autour de 10% plus que
l'espagne qui doit d'être autour de 12%
beaucoup plus que la suède à qui et à
6% donc on voit bien qu'il y a un
problème de coût et c'est peut-être à
cette notion de coût beaucoup plus qu'à
la question oui comme on vit plus
longtemps il faut qu'on puisse
travailler plus c'est beaucoup plus à la
question du coût que réagissent les
politiques alors et stages axa ne sera
pas soutenable à l'avenir et bien en
fait si et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que le conseil d'orientation des
retraites viendra à publier en 2020 un
rapport et on voit que en réalité ça va
beaucoup dépendre du tout croissance de
l'économie française on voit bien que si
on est avec un taux de croissance de 1,5
ou même 1,75
et bien s'arrête tout à fait soutenable
et même à partir de 2025 2030 on va
commencer à faire baisser la dette de
retraite autrement dit l'argent que le
système de retraite a été obligée
d'emprunter et le poids général des
retraites dans le pib va baisser par
contre effectivement si on se retrouve
avec un taux de croissance très faible
par exemple 1% par an la wii ce n'est
pas soutenable donc ce que l'on voit
c'est que c'est bien joli de parler
de l'allongement de la durée de la vie
et de ce genre de choses mais que
l'après variable la variable qui est
réellement pertinente c'est beaucoup
plus le taux de croissance alors
qu'elles sont maintenant les arguments
en faveur de la réforme structurelle sur
la question des réformes structurelles
c'était essentiellement un problème
d'équité et d'égalité entre les
personnes et c'est vrai et si vous
voulez ça je ne discute pas le fait
qu'il y ait des situations très
inégalitaire pourquoi parce que et c'est
en particulier le cas dans les régimes
spéciaux que l'on voulait et que l'on
veut supprimer 1 dans le cadre d'une
telle réforme eh bien on prenait mais il
ya 50 ans 60 ans on prenait des
professions qui était très pénible et
dans certaines de ces professions à la
pénibilité elle a fortement diminué
c'est le cas c'est très bien des
cheminots s'étaient pas du tout la même
chose d'être cheminots dans une motrice
à vapeur et de l'être maintenant dans un
tgv mais d'un autre côté on voit qu'il
ya toujours des professions qui reste
extrêmement pénible et ça se voit si
vous voulez sur le fait que l'âge de
départ disons l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé reste inférieur à 60 ans
donc on voit très bien qu'il ya toujours
des professions qui sont très pénibles
et ça pose un problème c'est que un
système par points ce qui était proposé
par emmanuel macron c'était aussi
proposé par la cfdt il faut le dire bon
un système par points s'il ne prend pas
en compte ces différences de situation
entre les professions et entre les
personnes eh bien il va aboutir à
reproduire d'autres inégalités qui
seront tout aussi important et c'est un
problème général mais chaque fois qu'on
rentre dans une logique que vous savez
une taille pour tout le monde le fameux
os
des anglais et bien là on va se
retrouver avec des phénomènes
d'inégalités extrêmement important dans
ce cas on se demande pourquoi emmanuel
macron tient autant à cette réforme
je pense qu'il ya trois raisons qui
peuvent se combiner d'ailleurs lors la
première est une errance une raison
purement politiciennes il sait que la
question de la réforme des retraites
elle plaît beaucoup à l'ancien électorat
de françois fillon d'ailleurs là et il
est en train de se
aller progressivement sur les
propositions économiques de françois
fillon et tombe pour la rue va faire une
réforme paramétrique comme le demandait
fillon comme ça il pourra dire voilà
j'ai fait ce que votre ancien candidat a
fait donc ça c'est une première un
raison une deuxième raison qui est tout
à fait possible c'est que ben voilà
l'union européenne demande à la france
depuis des années de faire cette réforme
et on sait bien emmanuel macron est un
grand européen et voilà il peut
peut-être vouloir la faire justement en
raison de cette demande urbaine et puis
une troisième raison qui me semble quand
même tout aussi pertinente c'est que
qu'est ce qui va se passer avec cette
réforme cette réforme
admettons qu'ils fassent justement sa
combinaison de réformes structurelles et
de réformes paramétriques sava
désavantager les personnes des classes
populaires de plus de 40 ans par contre
les entrepreneurs
de moins de 30 ans ou de moins de 35 ans
eux seront avantagés dans ce système et
finalement c'est une philosophie qui
correspond assez bien à
tout ce qu'on a entendu dans la bouche
de d'emmanuel macron les premiers de
cordée et inversement les gens qui ne
sont rien c'est a donc finalement c'est
assez cohérent de sa part de vouloir
faire cette réforme merci beaucoup
jacques sapir d'avoir été avec noé à la
semaine prochaine l'absolu mans